let's go next to john from is it
pronounced lester is that the correct
pronunciation
yeah no it's a lester we spoke before
actually i remember
i remember i always want to get because
in the us
there are towns in the u.s with the same
spelling but we call them leicester
that's fair i mean i used to call things
like that because i'm from south wales
so you probably i don't know if you can
notice in my accent i do different
mostly from most english people i always
press left bro luca beruga when i first
came here and people laugh which is fair
like but yeah well that's a whole other
story probably yeah
yeah i get really i wanted to talk to
you about i guess like mainly i guess
the current political climate i don't
know maybe i've been naive over these
last couple of years but i guess i i
don't know maybe you're about as worried
as i am about the overall rise in uh
right-wing opinions the against the pro
typical fascists
and how that affects our current like i
guess western outlook it sounds like i'm
at least as worried as you i mean we
have a few different things going on
first of all you have the rise of
right-wing
uh hyper or super nationalism and we've
seen that in a number of european
countries we're seeing it to some degree
in south america we're seeing it in a
lot of different places in addition to
that trump in the u.s
pulled a ton of people who were not
previously engaged with politics into
the political space and they're they're
almost exclusively horrible people and
some of them are like remaining involved
for now now depending on what happens
here in the u.s in november they may
become uh unengaged or disheartened and
we'll have to wait and see
but you then combine that
with the effect of the radicalizing
effect of social media's filter bubbles
and echo chambers which serves to
reinforce these radical beliefs and all
of it together is a recipe for exactly
the disaster that you're pointing out
i guess as well i guess it's hard to
hide right now at least because
currently from a british perspective the
influence as well of other powers on our
i guess electoral systems but already
now people are starting to talk in the
uk about how much russia had an effect
on the brexit vote right which was
invariably driven by people's vitriol
towards uh immigrants i can say that
leicester was the only part of the east
midlands that voted to remain the rest
all the other counties voted leave
leicester's proportionality wise it's
quite a diverse city it's quite nice to
live in but the county is it's like
99.94 white british leicester 40 white
british and then we pretty much i think
representation from 110 out of 140 or so
nations in the world
what is the population of leicester
oh about 300k i reckon it's got a
million in the leicester leicestershire
area oh i should know these things i do
i i've managed clinical projects in the
nhs that's very interesting and now you
mentioned white british
in
your area
is there a distinction made between
white british and like say french or
italian folks
i think so and again it depends on
probably the person you ask i think if
you can ask somebody for you asked me
i'd probably talk more demographically
if you were to speak to somebody who was
i guess like had more traditionalist
values let's say um they probably would
actually differentiate then again
further and go you know these people
eastern european they're western
european this is a it's quite a quite a
tricky situation in the uk a lot of
people have a lot of hatred towards
people particularly of eastern european
origin that's very very
community groups
yeah i mean you know one of the
interesting things in the united states
is that the definition of who's
considered white has changed over time
you know there was a period where darker
skinned southern italians were not
considered white now i think there are
very few people that would argue that
they are not white but then there's
questions as to whether you know are our
persians white and white supremacists
say well jews are not white and all
these different
it is very interesting how that changes
and it sounds like at least where you
are
there's there's still at least a
significant portion that sees
non-british western europeans as
something a little different at least
absolutely and like i think it's
definitely what drove a lot of people to
vote leave is this idea an antagonistic
view of it were towards i guess people
outside of britain yeah
i can't even escape but as a welsh
person i've never really been one for
nationalism but i mean yeah until the
difference between a welsh national
english nationalist language they speak
last thing as a welsh gentleman
how closely do you identify
sort of with like the london milieu and
culture like do you feel like that's
kind of what you're part of or do you
really feel like like you're in a very
different area
oh why'd you have to ask me about london
it's my least favorite city you know
absolutely
but i mean i guess what i'm trying to
get to is culturally do you feel like
you like lester and london are part of
the same thing or that it's really
different
i say it's similar but different i think
it's similar in the sense that it is
quite a diverse city and it is quite
metropolitan it's different in the level
of i guess access to public services and
healthcare like this is you know it's in
east midlands city because of the lack
of services whereas in london i guess
well london's always considered the
utopia when you speak to people it's the
london lifestyle and then the others i
like russia moscow i think
yeah i mean there's some in france
there's a lot of paris and then
everything else and then the folks in
brittany often think of themselves as
different as well that's yeah the
internal dynamics are interesting
because from far away like in the us
people just tend to have a sense of oh
there's france and then there's the uk
and then there's italy but within these
countries there are such dramatic
differences
absolutely i absolutely couldn't agree
more like no thanks for taking my
questions there all right john thank you
great to hear from you again
all right john from lester what a call
very very exciting there for sure
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video